one of the reasons that i mean obviously
you have a great natural gift but you
have been doing this you were acting in
the womb i believe that was your first
role
in the sonogram in the sonogram you
actually
they saw me
you were you were doing this i think
when you were two weren't you i was just
method acting
doing a lot of space work you know in
the placenta and people were like take
it easy
the doctor was like she's good she's
very she's really good very convincing
yeah um you started so young yes i did
well obviously my sister started you
know she's four years older than me and
you know this was not the plan like i
my whole family is all from has a sports
background my mom played tennis my dad
played professional baseball my mom's
dad was a quarterback in the nfl for the
eagles
like everyone was sports and my sister
and i were supposed to play tennis like
we were supposed to be
tennis sisters like venus and serena
and um it just my sister was older so
she kind of tried out all the activities
and she didn't like tennis she didn't
like it we were also
we're very you can
you know you're pale
and so i don't i'm sorry
[Laughter]
you know you know what this is this is
how white i am
l fanning just pointed at me and said
you're really white
that's as white as it gets
when i see kabuki theater the performers
are like oh my god look
look one of us one of us
i've had ghosts real ghosts stop me on
the street and say sunscreen
you're a ghost oh my god but anyway yes
you and i have as soon we are very pink
undertones i would say yeah
yeah and we sunburn very easily and my
sister does as well like my mom is very
tan so her out in the sun playing tennis
it doesn't affect her right as much as
it did my sister you and your sister
cannot be playing tennis out in the sun
yeah you can play it in an arena that's
close but you cannot play outside yeah
just when she was you know three or four
or out there i mean my mom had her out
there young she was probably too young
but she was like she just hated it she
was just baking and so my mom then put
her into this theater group
and she
she has a photographic memory so she was
five and she could memorize all the
lines and she
got the lead in the the play it was
called blue fish and she was the blue
fish in the place
and very young to be doing that but they
were like you should go to la or new
york and
i stayed at um in georgia because we
were born in georgia i stayed there with
my dad and my mom and my sister flew out
to l.a for pilot season oh wow and she
got 10 commercials in one week oh my god
yeah and then got i am sam the first
film that she did when she was six with
sean penn and my mom's like okay i guess
we're not coming home because all this
work is like
not coming home she calls home from a
mansion
i know we've only been gone a few days
but
we have a mansion on a large hill above
beverly hills so we flew over maybe yeah
i would think so yeah we're not leaving
georgia
and like we just never went back and
then obviously like seeing you know a
big sister she whatever she did i wanted
to do and so i kind of was tagging along
and um i played her and i am sam younger
oh um
i was my first thing because i was just
on i was on set like my mom was holding
me and the director was like they needed
someone for a flashback sequence for my
sister and she's like well obviously you
know you look like her so they threw me
in to i we went i had to swing on a
swing with sean penn and sleep in the
grass that was my first thing right you
know it's so funny you say that because
i'm thinking it just gave me the idea
that i should find someone who can play
me younger
you know because i'm getting old fast
when you were on the show and you were
13 i was like in my 40s i'm 77 now i
don't know what happened
and and you look exactly the same you're
a little older but uh i am rotting
quickly and so i i should find someone
who can play me younger like in life
voice yeah what's that will you still do
the voice or i want someone who would
just take over and be conan o'brien and
i'll be at home getting the checks okay
oh you know what i mean but it'll be a
younger acceptable coder it's like abuse
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can't do that yeah
i get no money no i would give them like
i would pay them hundreds of dollars a
week what are you talking about
they would get the fame though and you
know what we'll do we'll have you play
me younger
when there's a movie about my life
you'll play there'll be there'll be a
third pink undertone